previously on hunter x hunter
gome left his village to become a hunter
like his father while trying to pass the
hunter exams he met leorio kurapika
chilua
after passing the two exam phases the
group arrived at the third phase
location they have only 78 hours to get
down from the tower alive while inside
the tower they must face the prisoners
and win three out of five matches
against tower prisoners tompa takes the
first match with a hardened-looking
criminal and promptly gives up the story
continues with the gone-facing setakin
who proposes a match to see whose candle
burns the longest golden chooses the
longer candle unaware that it is oil
soaked and his candle starts to burn
faster midway seeing that his candle is
not susceptible to strong winds he puts
it down and sprints towards sedeken to
blow his candle out
the next match is between kuropika and
maj tani who proposes a death match
without weapons and with the condition
that one must die or surrender to finish
the match majestani who relies on
scaring and intimidating his enemies to
make them surrender gloats about how
many people he's killed and even keeps
multiple heart tattoos numbering them
kuropika notices a spider tattoo on
majtani's back and his eyes becomes
scarlet he easily defeats him with a
devastating punch knocking him out but
not killing him kuropika tells majtani
to remember three things
one a genuine phantom troop tattoo has
the member's number inscribed on the
spider tattoo's back
two
they have murdered so many people that
it would be impossible to count
three
do not ever mention the phantom troop
again or he will kill him the group
becomes frightened by kurepaka's
outburst and the others try to figure
out if karapika has a thing with spiders
he sits in the corner alone while the
prisoners think of their next strategy
elsewhere izoka enters a room where a
former examiner of the hunter exam named
togari has been waiting for him he wants
revenge for his oka scaring his face in
last year's exam hizoka calmly calls him
an incompetent examiner and tells him
that his own inadequacies are to blame
for his scars not him togarvey proceeds
to demonstrate his infinite quad
wielding curved knives skills showing it
partially before he starts attacking
hizoka hizoka however easily dodges the
knives getting only slightly wounded
tagari tells him that he has nowhere to
run and will be cut until he dies izoka
quickly learns the pattern in his attack
and gracefully catches two of the blades
before they hit him
he admits it would be impossible to stop
togari's attack and that the only way to
do so is to grab his blades
it took dogari half a year to learn how
to catch and throw those blades hizoka
tells him that catching the blades was
easier than he would have thought and
that he appreciates his feudal efforts
he quickly dispatches of togari by
decapitating him with his own blades
hizoka then moves on to become the first
to pass the third phase of the hunter
exam taking six hours and 17 minutes
meanwhile a prisoner named laerup bets
against lyorio whether manchtonia is
alive or dead using their time as
credits she proposes to use their
remaining 50 hours each and continue
until one party has no more time credits
to bet as a consequence if leorio loses
his team has lesser hours to escape the
tower but if larrou loses the time will
be added to her sentence leorio agrees
to the match and bets 10 hours that
majtani is alive he and larry check the
prisoner and confirm that he's not dead
yet fast forward larynx successfully
wins the next three bets reducing 50
hours from the examines a lot of time to
escape trick tower her sentence is also
reduced by 50 years the last match will
be jonas vs kilauea as lippo starts to
remove joma's handcuffs the other
prisoner starts to take a step back to
avoid him
jonas removes his face cover much to
leorio's alarm when he recognizes him
and he strongly advises killua to back
down
however killah ignores him and both of
them enter the platform kilauea then
asks how should they settle this match
which jonas replies that he does not
care about the exam and then he just
wants to kill him kiluat innocently
answers that the one who loses will die
before jumas can even make a move kiluah
has already ripped his heart out in an
instant shocking everyone
jonas pleads him to give his heart back
but in a matter of seconds he's dead a
small path suddenly appears which leads
them to a small room that they must wait
in for 50 hours
meanwhile giter accord is seen in the
finish line and is followed by hanzo
thus making guitar aqua be the second to
finish and hands of the third greta
manages to make it to the bottom of the
trick tower before the time runs out and
thus becomes the fourth person to finish
the third phase
with 40 hours left in the room gone and
kilauea keep themselves entertained by
doing many things
time continues to run until there is
only one minute left they'd all stand in
front of the door waiting impatiently
finally the long-awaited minute passes
and the door opens automatically gone
rushes out before anyone else makes a
move they begin their journey to the
bottom of the tower by getting through
various hurdles after many obstacles
their time is one hour and they all
arrive in a small room with two doors
the first door has an x mark on it while
the second door has an o mark
they encounter a very difficult choice
the first is to choose the door with o
mark that allows five to pass but is
long and difficult which requires a
minimum of four to five hours while the
second is to choose the door with the x
mark that is short and easy which
requires only three minutes but only
allows three to pass tompo who is
becoming impatient grabs and axe and
attacks lior they begin fighting while
kurupika and gon convince them to stop
suddenly gong gets a bright idea by
watching tampa break the wall with his
axe they all press o and when they are
inside they break the wall that
separates both paths using the axe with
the time almost out gone kilwa and
kurapika arrive first followed by lorio
and tampa behind them
with that they all have passed the third
phase of the hunter exam
24 candidates have completed trick tower
and passed the hunter exam's third phase
lippo congratulates them on escaping
trick tower he tells them that only the
fourth and final phase remain in the
fourth phase will take place on zebel
island a trick tower's third examiner
comes with a wheel table with a box on
it he then tells them they need to draw
lots he examines act surprise and lipo
tells them it is to determine who will
hunt and who there are 24 cards with id
numbers on them and they will draw in
the order they exited the tower izuka is
the first to draw the number 384
kuropika draws number 16 after killua
adra's number 199
gone is next and he draws number 44. the
oreo is last and draws with style number
246 and tampa draws number 403 lippo
informs them to remove the seal on their
cards and reveal the number on it he
explains that the number revealed is
their target many candidates immediately
cover their badges goat is shocked to
have drawn izoka's number lipboat tells
the candidates that the box has recorded
which card was drawn by who the
examiners are allowed to use any method
they choose to steal a badges which
includes killing their target lippo
explains the rules further their badges
is worth three points their own is also
worth three points if kept in their own
possession and that all other badges are
worth one point they will need six
points in total to advance to the final
phase
a small steamboat heads for several
island as their new guy kara commends
them for their excellent work during the
third phase and introduces herself
telling them it will take two hours for
the boat to reach zebel island kara
tells them they are free to do what they
want for the next two hours and to enjoy
the boat ride
leorio asked if he is kura because
target and if you show him any mercy
kurapika answers that he is not his
target and he should not worry he walks
away and lyorio amberly shouts that he
isn't his target either hiluwa
approaches gon and asks what number he
drew
gon asks killah but he says it's a
secret they laugh and killua assures him
that he is not his target bone says the
same killah immediately realizes that
number 44 belongs to hizoka and tells
gone he has bad luck
gone asks who number 199 is kiluah
doesn't know either and he didn't bother
to memorize everyone's number thinking
the game is lame the boat arrives at
devil island and cara thanks them for
their patience
kara explains that they will be on zebul
island for a week and they must amass
six points before returning to the
landing site she calls for the first
person hizoka kurapika comments that
those who disembark earlier hold the
advantage
hirakra then exits the ship frightening
kara from the way he looks kiluah
decides to scout the area first
kara calls gon telling lyorio that he
will see him later he then runs off the
boat and onto the island thinking that
first he must find hisoka's location
after everyone is out of the ship
gone wonders how he will get hizoka's
tag while hanging upside down from a
branch he comes to the conclusion that
he can't steal his okas tag head on he
spots hugh with a sword in a long grassy
area below
he then notices that there is another
candidate pockel behind the candidate he
is targeting hub is aware of someone's
presence pockel aims his ball at q
hugh senses the attack and manages to
dodge
however it slices his arm injuring him
hugh tells popple that was close pockle
stands up and q warns him that he won't
be so easy
he suddenly starts to lose control over
his body and falls down wondering what
has happened pockle explains that the
arrow was coated with a fast acting
tranquilizer and he won't be able to
walk for the next week but then you
shouldn't worry since there's water
nearby so he won't die he rummages
through queue's backpack and collects
his badge gum is amazed at how
pacomaster's presence while stalking his
prey he now understands how to approach
ahzoka
gohan grabs his fishing rod and jumps
off the tree he can steal his oka's
plate with his rod he practices with his
fishing rod getting apples from wood
logs in one swing
he knows he'll need to sneak up on
hizoka without him realizing and then
wait for the chance to get his badge
during this time gone is being watched
by goretta his predator he realizes he
shouldn't forget that hizuka will try to
get out of the way of his attack he
decides to try to catch a bird by
observing how it moves or he'll never be
able to catch his zoka's tag
he tries the first time but fails
meanwhile leorio walks through the dark
forest wondering whose number he has
kurapika on a cliff looking at the
sunset decides he should probably stay
in one place
the next day has now arrived and we see
gome washing his face in the river gone
realizes there may be a moment when his
opponent will target another and he will
be able to intervene
he finally manages to catch a bird which
is about to catch a fish that is about
to catch a fly doan is overjoyed
loretta who has been watching him is
surprised that he has actually mastered
the art of hunting
however his intense concentration will
be his undoing
though notices that his hands are
drenched in blood and blister from
practicing for two days straight the
scent of blood attracts hemotropic
butterflies
gone then recalls seeing hizouka wounded
on his shoulder from trick tower he
takes advantage of this by using the
hemotropic butterflies to lead him to
hizoka's location
don finds his oka and sits quietly in
bushes to hide his presence waiting for
the right opportunity to strike
meanwhile lyorio has a run-in with tompa
tompa is collaborating with so many
steel badges however kuropika halts
tampa and they proceed to tie him up and
leave him on random rock with a sign
behind him reading please do not feed
they soon catch somi and his pet monkey
too leoria receives his badge back and
karapika takes tampa's badge having a
total of six points to clear the fourth
phase
at the break of dawn hizouka senses
someone nearby in the bushes and he
proceeds to walk towards them
gon thinks that hizoka notices him but
it turns out to be goes goes challenges
hizouka to a duel allowing gon an
opportunity to strike while hizoka is
attacking his prey those relentlessly
attacks while hisoka dodges effortlessly
goes collapses from a fatal wound he
received before confronting hizoka
hisoka knows goes wanted to die in
battle but even so he still refuses to
fight him because in his oka's eyes goes
is already dead goes and rage bolts
towards hizoka but out of nowhere he's
struck down by giterakor's needles
instantly killing him
hirako removes the pins from his face
morphing into another one and is
revealed to be a comrade of hizoka he
gives hizouka another's badge and having
six points of his own to pass the fourth
phase he digs a hole and decides to
sleep on it until the final day
on the evening of the second day hizoka
begins to search for his target and
comes across lyorio and kurapika
hiding in the bushes still stalking
hizoka gone awaits when he can attack
unbeknownst to gone however hizouka has
found his own prey in kurapika and
lyorio he runs after his oka torn
between what to do help them or stick to
his plan to steal his oka's tag
he quickly picks the more honorable
choice helping his friends if they need
it hizoka greets them leaning on a tree
he asks for their badges needing two
points and lyorio quickly refuses
kurupika figures they must not be his
target so he begins to negotiate he
tells his zoka the badges he has but
neither are helpful filling the air with
more and more tension
gonna waits nearby eavesdropping on the
conversation kurapika offers the badge
that has no meaning for him and if that
still is not enough he challenges hizoka
to take the others by force hizoka
merely laughs at their feeble threat and
accepts the initial deal kuropika leaves
the badge in a tree and leaves with
lyorio
thomas sits frozen behind a tree still
ripping onto his fishing rod and
sweating
hizouka comments to himself he is happy
about their progression but they still
have much to learn the home becomes
anxious from the thought of the next
person hizoka meets not fighting either
when suddenly hisoka's killing intent
drastically increases it scatters the
nearby animals and frightens go into no
end hizoka's bloodlust has risen to a
point that must be satisfied
the next day after hizoka hunts his next
victim boom begins to follow once again
he believes whoever hisoka runs into
next will be attacked no matter what so
he runs ahead to find them he spots agon
heading in the opposite direction of
hizoka and pixel vantage point his
nerves begin to sway as his heart beats
out of his chest
he knows he must completely hide his
presence while taking deep breaths
just then hisoka stops sensing someone
it is add-on
he dashes forward an insane look on his
face
again sees azoka almost too late and
draws his sword gone readies is fishing
rod anticipating the attack
hisoka takes out one of his cards and
shouts a chilling scream
gone wins back his fishing rod and let
it loose agon thrusts forward with his
sword missing hizoka's head by
centimeters hizouka is so entranced by
the thought of killing agon bone's
fishing hook is able to catch on to his
tag
hizoka notices too late the tag has been
reeled in hizouka and avon stand after
the instantaneous exchange agon falls
dead to the ground while hizouka has
already moved on to the matter of his
tag
gone stands up and catches the tag which
lands perfectly in his hand
unfortunately hizouka sees this and
looks as stunned as gon does instead of
being upset though izoka smiles
gon rushes off into the brush trying to
get as far away from his okay as
possible before he can truly celebrate
he loses control of his body paralyzed
and collapses to the ground
loretta appears telling gone how many
times he could have killed him loretta
commands gone for his concentration
while training with his fishing rod but
adds how open he was for the attack he
mentions gohan was so focused on hizoka
he didn't check his own surroundings he
takes both hizoka and gone's tags and
leaves
gon is left alone with his shame of
losing
not a moment later goretta falls dead
next to gon his oka stands over him with
a smile on his face expressing how
impressed he is with gone's ability to
hide his presence his timing and attack
he drops gones in his own tags giving
them back to gone for a job well done
loretta was his opus target so he no
longer needs his but gone doesn't want
his opus tag in this way remarkably gome
is able to stand with a paralyzing drug
that lasts 10 days from normal people he
tells hizouka to take his tag back but
hisoka refuses keeping going alive so
one day he can kill gohan when he's more
experienced hizoka hits going with a
ferocious punch to the face and says
he'll take his tag back once gone can do
the same to him he walks off leaving
gone later that night gone sits alone in
a tree having won but also lost
and this was the end of part two
like always the links for the next parts
will be available in description and
pinned in the comments section
subscribe and hit the notification bell
so you don't miss the next part